And the answer here is no, we cannot.
And the reason is as follows; so when we simulate nondeterminism
on a deterministic RAM, what we have is here--a polynomial--
and here we have 2 to the power of that polynomial,
which essentially was needed for trying all possibilities for using the "if better" function
or nondeterminism, if you will.
Now if we tried the same thing over here, what we would have--we would have
a nondeterministic machine that runs in     2^p(n) time.
Now if you wanted to simulate this on a deterministic RAM,
what you could have in the worst case is a running time of 2 ^2^p(n),
which does not fall into this category here anymore because we said that
exponential time was 2^p(n) and not 2 to the power of some exponential function of n.
So you must not make the mistake that simply because we can simulate NP
in exponential time, we can also simulate
nondeterministic exponential time in exponential time.
But given how bad these running times here are, you will, of course,
not come across them very often in practice.